-With just four weeks to go
until the pivotal
midterm elections
and early voting about to start
in some crucial states,
Republicans and Democrats
have settled
on very different strategies.
Republicans in key
battleground races
that will determine control
of Congress
have decided to fully embrace
Donald Trump,
even as the federal
criminal investigation
into his stolen classified
documents intensifies.
President Biden, meanwhile,
is taking the first steps
towards decriminalizing
marijuana.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
As much as we may all want him
to disappear into the sunset,
Donald Trump is still
very much playing
a central role
in Republican politics
and, specifically,
the GOP's campaign
to take back control
of Congress.
Just this weekend, he traveled
to Nevada and Arizona,
two crucial battleground states
with tight races
for both governor and Senate,
and yet, even though Trump
is theoretically supposed
to be there to campaign
for other candidates,
he always, without exception,
makes it about himself.
[ Laughter ]
He's like the best man
at a wedding
who gives a drunken toast
about how awesome he is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Trump ] I remember
when Jake came up to me
sophomore year.
Big guy, strong guy, tears,
[ Laughter ]
tears pouring down his face,
and he said to me,
he told me he just met Sarah
and he needed advice from me
because I was the smartest
and sexiest guy he knew.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I told him -- I told him
these exact words.
He'll remember it.
[ Laughter ]
I told him.
He'll remember.
I said, "If you love her,
you got to get a ring and lock.
-[Both] her. up!
[ Laughter and applause ]
For example,
Trump was in Nevada on Saturday
to campaign
with the GOP candidates
for Senate and governor,
Adam Laxalt and Joe Lombardo,
who both got up to speak.
After Lombardo's remarks,
he could be heard asking Trump
if he should stay
up onstage with him
and I want you to guess
Trump's response.
-Thank you, sir.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
-Thank you, sir.
-Okay, sir.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks, sir.
-[ As Trump ]
No, no, no, no.
Off, off you go...
[ Laughter ]
You thought Donald Trump would
share a stage with you?
This is a guy who once literally
shoved another world leader...
[ Laughter ]
...at a NATO summit to get
to the front of the group.
I'm shocked Trump didn't pick
Lombardo up over his head
and throw him off the stage
WWE-style.
Also, I love how sheepishly
he asked Trump
if he should stay
up there with him.
He's like an actor
asking a table of producers
if he can audition
a second time.
"Do you, um --
[ Clears throat ]
Do you want me
to do that line again?"
Uh, no. You can, uh, just get
the [bleep] on outta here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And you can actually, uh,
take the head shot.
[ Laughter ]
And then
on Sunday,
Trump went to Arizona,
ostensibly, to campaign
with Blake Masters
and Kari Lake,
the GOP candidates
for Senate and governor.
But again, he could not help
but rant about his own problems,
including the federal
criminal investigation
into the classified documents
he stole from the White House.
Now, any normal person
in that situation
might stay out of the spotlight
or, at the very least,
avoid talking about the case
in public.
But Trump, as we all know,
is not normal
and, during that rally
in Arizona,
Trump decided just essentially
to confess.
-I had a small number of boxes
in storage at Mar-A-Lago,
guarded by Secret Service
and my people and everybody.
I mean, it's safe.
There is no crime.
You know, there is no crime.
It's not a crime.
[ Laughter ]
And they should give me,
immediately, back
everything that they've taken
from me
[ Laughter ]
because it's mine. It's mine.
[ Cheering and applause ]
They took it
from me in the raid.
They broke into my house!
-The key quote there is
when he says, "It's mine."
That shows you it wasn't just
some misunderstanding.
He didn't take the classified
documents by accident.
He took them on purpose because
he thinks they belong to him.
And, when you're proving
a crime, criminal intent is key.
I know that because I watch
a show called...
[ Laughter ]
It's right there in the title.
There was never a "Law & Order"
spinoff called...
[ Laughter ]
And then Trump decided
to reel off a truly insane story
about what other presidents
had done
with their own
presidential records.
-George H.W. Bush
took millions
of documents
to a former bowling alley
and a former Chinese restaurant,
where they combined them,
so they're in a bowling alley/
Chinese restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, usually, this would be
the part of "A Closer Look"
where I carefully dissect
that insanity,
but instead, I want to see
what it would feel like
to actually believe him.
[ Laughter ]
Which brings us
to a new segment called
"Seth Takes Donald Trump
at His Word."
[ Shimmering tune plays ]
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
When you tell me
George H.W. Bush
took millions of documents
to a bowling alley/
Chinese restaurant,
I believe you.
[ Laughter ]
I believe you
because I don't think
you'd ever make
something up like that.
[ Laughter ]
And here's how I believe
it happened.
George H.W. Bush
was leaving office
and packed up millions
of documents,
loaded them into what was
probably multiple trucks.
And then his family
came out and said,
"Whoa, Dad!
What are you doing?!"
And he said,
"I'm in a super bad mood
about only serving one term.
Get out of my way!"
And they said, "You can't just
take all these documents."
And he said,
"Not only am I taking them,
I am taking them to a bowling
alley/Chinese restaurant...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...where I intend to spend
my retirement picking up spares,
knocking down wontons,
and reading state secrets
at my leisure!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And if you think I'm turning
these trucks around,
let me assure you I'm --"
[ As Dana Carvey's Bush ]
Not gonna do it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
At which point,
Barbara turned to her kids
and she said, "You know what?
Just let him go."
[ Laughter ]
And that is why,
to this day, if you're in Texas,
you can stop by...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This has been "Seth Takes
Donald Trump at His Word."
[ Shimmering tune plays ]
Got to say, you guys,
it's pretty fun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I can see why people
at his rallies
are having such a good time.
[ Laughter ]
Again, I want to emphasize
these aren't obscure appearances
we have to go digging for.
These are rallies
Trump is holding
with GOP candidates
in key battleground states
to win back control of Congress.
He thinks he's actually
helping those candidates.
Biden, meanwhile, is taking
an entirely
different approach --
doing things people like.
For example,
polls have repeatedly shown
that voters overwhelmingly say
marijuana should be legal
for medical
and recreational use.
And last week, Biden took
an important first step
toward decriminalizing
marijuana.
-President Biden is taking
his first major steps
toward
decriminalizing marijuana.
Today, he pardoned thousands
of Americans convicted
on federal possession charges,
simple possession cases,
dating back to the 1990s.
-That clears
about 6,500 people convicted
between 1992 and 2021.
And he is also urging governors
to pardon those convicted
of state charges, which make up
for the vast majority
of convictions.
The president is also
ordering his administration
to review how marijuana
is classified,
saying that it makes no sense
that it is a Schedule I drug
in the same class
as heroin and LSD.
-You know, Biden always had
that vibe of a grandpa who,
if he caught you smoking weed,
would scold you
and then take a long hit...
[ Laughter ]
...before telling you
he spent a summer
as a roadie
for Grand Funk Railroad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is obviously huge news
and a long overdue first step
toward criminal justice reform
and undoing the racist
and disproportionate impacts
of our deeply inhumane
drug laws.
No one should be in jail
for something you can buy
at a boutique in Beverly Hills.
There are states in this country
where you can find
a high-end weed dispensary
with all kinds of fancy edibles
in a strip mall right next
to a...
-Bowling alley/
Chinese restaurant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But on top of being
the right thing to do,
it might also explain a lot
because there have been times
when Biden has gotten stuck
onstage
in a way that makes me think
he might've just taken
a giant bong rip...
[ Laughter ]
...and the weed is just starting
to kick in.
[ As Biden ]
Whoa!
Can anyone like see me?
Am I --
[ Laughter ]
Did I turn into a statue?
And then there's this moment
from Thursday, where,
for some reason,
Biden just started
silently backing away
from reporters,
once he decided he didn't want
to answer any more questions.
-No, the trip was not
essentially for oil.
The trip was
about the Middle East
and about Israel and --
and rationalization
of positions.
But it is a disappointment
and it says
that there are problems.
-Are you worried about --
-[ Clamoring ]
[ Laughter ]
-What is he doing?
Is he trying to do
the Homer Simpson meme?
[ Laughter and applause ]
You can't --
You can't disappear.
You're on camera
in front of the most famous
building in the world.
We can all see you.
It's like trying
to Irish goodbye a meeting
in your own office.
[ Laughter ]
So,
those are the quarterly
sales reports.
A little bit lower
than we expected.
And now, before I answer
what I assume will be
some very angry
shareholder questions,
I'm just going to head
to the bathroom
and I will be right back.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I'll just wait here
until they're gone.
[ Laughter ]
And then after, I guess,
attempting to moonwalk
away from reporters,
[ Laughter ]
Biden made this
unfortunate gaffe
at a manufacturing event
on Friday.
-Let me start off
with two words --
Made in America.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ As Biden ]
Greatest band ever?
[ Inhaling sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
Two words --
Grand Funk Railroad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, even though this news
was both hugely popular
and a big step toward a fairer
and more sane drug policy,
it won't surprise you to learn
that not everyone was pleased.
Specifically,
Fox News had some issues,
although I'm not sure
they all made sense.
-Joe is rolling out
a political Hail Mary
and today, one year after firing
or suspending dozens
of White House staffers
for past marijuana use,
well, Biden announced
a widespread pardon
to anybody convicted
of marijuana possession
on the federal level.
-Well, it starts
with marijuana,
but where does it go from there?
-I think it's so cynical
because the question
of the impact
of drugs on our kids
and our societies is immense.
-Now, I want to describe
the left's midterm agenda
very simply.
You ready?
This is what they're going
to give you more of,
if you elect them --
abortion, pot, porn,
and more January 6th hearings.
-Man, sounds awesome.
Just add in a bowling alley/
Chinese restaurant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Feel like that's
a great night out.
It's so funny, how right-wing
pundits always have this way
of making Democrats sound better
than they actually are.
Also, where did the porn thing
come from?
[ Laughter ]
Did they just
throw that in there
without any good reason?
Is there some secret
pro-porn legislation proposed
by Chuck Schumer
that I'm not aware of?
[ Laughter ]
Because he definitely
lowers his glasses
like a guy who's seeing porn
for the very first time.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Schumer ]
Yowza, that is
some pretty steamy stuff.
[ Laughter ]
Also,
check out this graphic
Sean Hannity put
up on the screen.
Why does Fox keep accidentally
making Joe Biden look cooler
than he actually is
with their graphics?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, last week,
Tucker Carlson
aired this badass graphic
[ Laughter and applause ]
of Biden eating ice cream
in front of a burning building
and now, Hannity airs this.
This looks like something
you'd have up on the wall
in your college dorm room.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, with the midterms looming,
Republicans and Democrats
have clearly settled
on different strategies.
Biden's trying to appeal
to voters
with policies that are
overwhelmingly popular in polls,
like reforming marijuana laws;
while Republicans embrace
Donald Trump,
even as he rants
about bowling alleys
and Chinese restaurants,
like a guy who's on...
-Heroin and LSD.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up, so,
to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter registration
status or to register to vote.